you guys had the opportunity to swap
roles with anybody in the Star Wars film
franchise but would you go get it easy
oh yeah cool if he's one of coolest like
I'm sorry we saw yesterday and like
there are some gestures he does when he
does the things that he does so cool
like oh wow that's what the roles with
with Jenna because she's super cool has
an amazing big hair and gets the ride
like all the time kylo Ren rolls pretty
it's pretty good snazzy in a particular
answer today what would if I could the
darkness yes cuz you can just like not
you know just unleash all of that yeah
yeah the helmet stresses me out it just
doesn't look comfortable to be in that
most of the day
but it's it's really fun actually
there's like it's like helmets are
awesome is it that all comfortable for
you no okay
Oh bobble Frick Wow Oh all our guy yeah
for talk I don't want to be a little guy
that's amazing I always wanted to be
taller I think any costume in which you
can actually sit down you know kind of
like trousers jeans something I'd say
Adam
everybody everybody wants kylo Ren well
he gets to do so much fun stuff and I
mean obviously a lot of that has to do
with his brilliant performing but
especially in this one actually he he
has like some real funny moments he's
obviously a mean guy but there's so much
I think really is his performance
there's so much vulnerability and
insecurity within that states it's yeah
it's just fun but I don't think anyone
could do it like he does yeah that's a
good question that's hard to answer on
the fly
oh I'm so far or almost everyone has
said you me yes oh it has to be someone
within this be any film you want
probably Jabba the Hutt he doesn't have
to go anywhere people give him grapes a
lot he has like a little guy that runs
errands for him he doesn't have to worry
about weight or time or really anything
he gets to watch a show where you know
this is just going to a dark place with
her death and murder and he just enjoys
it I'll skip over that I'll just say
Jabba the Hutt for personal reasons